Jimmy and Jerry devino yes
and another guy with a hat they all wear
hats they're all suspicious yeah
wonderful that was that was surprisingly
good
um
I enjoyed this thing back there that's
the greatest backhanded compliment I've
heard in such a long time really I thank
you sir really I heard things about you
and then when you I said they're good
they're good they're good I think that's
the best band on television I really
believe I really believe thank you I'll
say it thank you Cable
cable television uh
now if you don't mind I want to start by
congratulating you today you had your
hand and footprint ceremony yes at the
Chinese Theater here in Los Angeles this
is one of the most iconic
yeah when I
you know when I was a little kid when I
first came out here uh first of all I
was walking down the street it was just
1952.
and it was like somebody in somebody's
backyard they were orange trees
and their oranges in the street
I took one
nobody said anything
I peeled it and I ate it nobody said
anything
I took another one I peeled it and I ate
it
nobody said anything
I called my brother one day I said come
to California you can eat all the
oranges
they're just going around the street
nobody says anything yeah but anyway I
went to the
I went to the ground once it was called
grandma's and Grandma's Chinese Theater
and I saw all these
you know Carol Lombard and George Raft
and Clark Gable and you know and
Vivian Blaine I don't know what she was
doing but anyway there was a lot of
people there
was a lot of there was a lot of people
there and I I was thrilled and today
[Music]
I
I was you do that to help yourself yeah
today I was honored literally honored by
the the Chinese Theater asking me to put
my hands and feet my name and date in
cement alongside all these things
Legends this is fantastic so and I am
now part of it I wanted to do something
just you know a little different I
didn't know I didn't know what
so uh
I got another finger
[Applause]
[Music]
that's fantastic somebody you know
somebody somebody's going to come in
from Des Moines Iowa and say
mother mother come on
is it Mel Brooks lifetimes you have six
fingers
yes father he's got six feet
he grew up near the nuclear plant yeah I
remember that
God that looks so good it's so realistic
now you don't have to pay up your mafia
loans
[Laughter]
and director sometimes he's actually
good
today I'm awake today